welcome to the presentation on exponents
if I were to ask you what let me make
sure this pen is the right width if I
were to ask you what 2 times 3 is well I
think at this point this should be
pretty easy for you that's the same
thing as 2 plus 2 plus 2 which equals 6
and you didn't have to do this we all
know that 2 times 3 is equal to 6 so
what we're going to do now is we're
going to learn exponents which are the
same the same thing that multiplication
is to addition exponents are to
multiplication and I'll explain that in
a second I know that probably confused
you if I were to say what 2 to the third
power is instead of 2 plus 2 plus 2 this
is equal to 2 times 2 times 2 which
equals 8 or if I were to say 3 to the
second power that is equal to 3 times 3
and remember 3 times 2 would be 3 plus 3
and so this first this first 3 times 3
this equals 9 and 3 plus 3 equals 6 and
the reason why I'm doing this is because
there's always this temptation when you
first learn exponents is to multiply
when I first learned it I saw 3 3 to the
2nd power 3 squared I'd always be like
oh that's 6 but you also remember it
unless 3 times 3 which equals 9
let's do some more problems if I were to
tell you negative 4 squared once again
that's the same thing as negative 4
times negative 4 well we don't learn
from the multiplying negative numbers
that a negative times a negative is a
positive
and then it's 4 times 4 well this equals
positive 16 you don't have to write the
positive I'm just doing
for emphasis if I were to ask you what
negative four to the third power is well
that equals negative four times negative
four times negative four well we know
already that negative four times
negative four that this equals sixteen
positive sixteen and then we multiply
that times negative four and then that
equals minus 64 so something very
interesting here to observe when I took
a negative number we call this the base
when the base is negative in the case of
negative four and I raise it to an even
power I got a positive number right
negative four to an even power was
positive sixteen and when I took a
negative number to an odd power to the
three I got a negative number and that
makes sense because every time you
multiply by a negative number again it
switches signs I'll show you the the I
guess you could call it the simplest
example negative 1 to the 1 power is
equal to negative 1 right because that's
just negative 1 times itself one time
and if I said negative 1 squared well
that's negative 1 times negative 1 well
that equals positive 1 but then if I
said negative 1 to the third power well
once again that's negative 1 times
negative 1 times negative 1 well now
this equals negative 1 times negative 1
is positive 1 times negative 1 equals
negative 1 again
and so you could I can tell you what
negative 1 to the 51st power is 51 is
odd if we know that that is equal equal
to negative 1 if it was a 50 that it
would be a positive 1 I hope I didn't
confuse you too much let's do a couple
more problems
if I asked you what five to the third
power is well that's going to 5 times 5
times 5 which equals 125 similarly if I
were to ask you at 5 negative 5 to the
third power is that would be negative 5
times negative 5 times negative 5 which
would be negative 125 now one principle
of exponents that might not seem
completely intuitive you at first is
when I raise something to the zero power
so let's say I had two to the zero power
it turns out that anything to the zeroth
power is equal to one so two to 0 power
is 1 3 to the 0 power is equal to 1
negative 900 to 0 power is equal to 1
and let me see if I can give you a
little bit of intuition of why that is
actually the case that's not erasing oh
there you go so if I were to ask you
let's do 3 to the fourth power that
equals 3 times 3 times 3 times 3 which
equals 81 3 to the third power third
power is equal to 27 just 3 times 3
times 3 3 the second power is equal to 9
3 to the first power is equal to 3 and
now we're going to say what's 3 to the 0
power well we already know I already
told you the rule anything that the
zeroth power is equal to 1 but this
would hopefully give you some intuition
when we went from the fourth part of the
third power we divided by 3 right 81
divided by 3 is 27
when you work from the 3rd power to the
2nd power we divided by 3 we move it
from the 2nd power from 9 to 3 we
divided by 3 so it kind of makes logical
sense that when we go from the first
power to the
both power will just divide by three
again so three divided by three is one
hopefully that gives you a little bit of
an intuitive sense you might want to
replay that and think about why that is
and there's actually other aspects of
exponents that why this would also make
sense why something to the zeroth power
is equal to one but let's just do some
more problems in the time we have I
don't want to get you too confused so if
I were to ask you seven squared on a
seven times seven that's 49 49 if I ask
you negative six to the third power
parenthesis around here so you notice
the whole negative six to the third
power that equals negative six times
negative six times negative six negative
six times negative six is positive 36
times negative six and that equals one
it's 180 and 36 that's minus 216 if my
mental math is correct you could have
actually multiplied it out but if we did
I think you're getting the point at this
point if we said oh and another thing if
I told you 0 to the hundredth power well
that's pretty easy that's zero times
itself 100 times which is still equal to
zero if I were to ask you 1 to the
thousandth power well that's just equal
to one right you can multiply 1 by
itself as many times as you want and
you're still going to get one and
remember if I had negative 1 to the one
thousand powers well this is an even
exponent so you're still going to get
one if it was negative one to the one
thousand and one then it would be
negative one I think you remember why
this is because when you multiply a
negative times itself an even number of
times the negatives cancel out and then
if you multiply it by a negative one
more time it becomes a negative number
again but let's just reduce some normal
problems and I just wanna make sure you
get the basics of exponents down if I
were to tell you
let me think of a good one eight squared
that equals eight times eight equals 64
if I were to tell you 25 squared plus 25
times 25 equals 625 powers of two all is
very interesting it's especially
interesting if you wanted a go into
computer science the two to the fourth
power that's 2 times 2 times 2 times 2
so 2 times 2 is 4 and 2 times 2 is 4
this is equals 16 and I did something
very interesting here kind of on purpose
notice that 2 to the 4th 2 to the 4th is
equal to 4 times 4 right because we did
4 times 4 here and I'm going to detail
this more later on but I want to think
about what that means because for itself
is the same thing as 2 squared so we
learned just real fast to the fourth
it's the same thing as 2 squared times 2
squared so I'll let you sit and think
about that but other than that I think
you have the general idea of what how
basic exponents work and I think you're
ready to try the level 1 exponent module
have fun